the time has finally come Star Wars the
Clone Wars is back on our screens taking
its final turn on Disney Plus after
spending nearly six years in the dark
here's the first episode of Star Wars
the clone wars final season explained
entitled the bad batch this episode
opens with an epigraph that reads
embrace others for their differences for
that makes you whole
it's then revealed that the rocky planet
of an axis which holds Republic
shipyards is under attack from Admiral
trenches separatist forces a massive
tarantula like being with cybernetic
enhancements Admiral trench and his
forces face the two-pronged assault that
mace Windu and Anakin Skywalker lead on
the ground and in the air but after
weeks of battling the Republic's
strength begins to fade in efforts to
break up their string of losses the
Republic forces take a moment to
evaluate their past mistakes and come up
with a new strategy
you see enemy forces have been
consistently outsmarting the plans of
skilled Clone Trooper at Captain Rex
this has left the clones vulnerable to
droid attacks the more they use any
given tactic speaking with mace and
Anakin Rex theorizes that the
separatists are using analytics to
predict the clones strategy and because
their counter-attacks are so specific
they must know Rex's playbook the losses
we are experiencing on an axis are not
commonplace
it's my strategy that droids know my
playbook but that's only part of Rex's
theory as to why the Republic is losing
as he tells Commander Cody immediately
after their meeting with the generals
Rex believes his fallen friend echo is
behind all of this
Commander Cody insists that it's
impossible for echo to be alive given
that he died at the Citadel on Lola saw
you when trying to secure transport and
escaped enemy forces as a reminder this
all happened on season 3 during the 2011
episode counter-attack Captain Rex
continues on nonetheless explaining that
the way the droids are countering the
Republic on an axis implies they know
his strategies which are all battle
plans that he and echo drew up together
though Commander Cody is firm in his
belief that it's impossible echo is
alive Rex says that echos fingerprints
are all over the separatist strategies
he posits that echo has been brainwashed
in some way forced to hand over
to the separatists every move the clones
would make from there Rex and Cody round
up a small crew of clones to lead the
separatist cyber center and discover the
truth behind the situation the group is
cloned force 99 better known as the bad
batch a foursome of mutant clone
troopers comprised of crosshair hunter
tech and wrecker they each have their
own quirks crosshair isn't much of a
conversationalist but is an expert
marksman while tech could talk someone's
ear off about random facts and form a
tense dynamic with Captain Rex and
Commander Cody who they call regs the
usual action and intensity ensues as Rex
cody and the bad batch face off against
a pack of battle droids and a sea of
creepy crawling Robo spiders which
leaves Cody wounded when that fight is
over and a minor spat is had in the
aftermath the crew agrees to follow
captain Rex's plan to infiltrate the
cyber center they soon take hold of an
outpost near the cyber center blasting
separatist droids left and right as the
background music swells Admiral trench
states that the clones must know about
the algorithm since there's no clear
advantage to seizing the outpost after
tech and Rex make their way into a hub
of the outpost tech taps into the
separatist computers and analyzes its
data / Rex's instructions he locates the
particular program Rex mentions which
turns out to not be a program at all but
instead a live signal originating from
sky co miner a planet controlled by the
techno Union an analysis of the audio
transmission uncovers a shocking truth
an individual who sent it bears the
operating name CT 1409 echoes number the
closing moments of star wars the clone
war season 7 episode 1 double down on
what's going on echo is alive and has
indeed been relaying the clones tactics
to the separatists that number can what
did it mean
zt1 4:09 that was echos number
he's alive clearly the biggest aspect of
the Clone Wars final season premiere
that needs unpacking regards echo and
who he is nicknamed for his ability to
follow orders so well it seemed like he
was echoing words through actions echo
was a member of the Domino squad a Clone
Trooper Cadet unit led by commanding
officer heavy and including fellow
clones cut up droid bait and the
much-loved fives stationed on Kamino
where they completed their Citadel
challenge to graduate into the Grand
Army of the Republic the Domino squad
faced tragedy when they moved to Rishi
Station and were tasked along with
Captain Rex with protecting the Rishi
moon base separatist struck down on them
killing the majority of the squad only
echo and fives remained on the Domino
squad and the two went on to join the
501st legion after Jedi generals obi-wan
Kenobi and Anakin Skywalker commended
them for their bravery and promoted them
to the rank of arc trooper on the Clone
Wars season 3 episode counter-attack
echo and his 500 and first Legion
teammates ventured into Lola saw you in
efforts to rescue Jedi Master Evan peel
from prison in the Citadel and obtained
from him coordinates to the Nexus
hyperspace route peel died in the midst
of the chaos and while attempting to
escape after the mission was deemed
successful echo seemingly died as well
the Clone Wars season 7 premiere doesn't
reveal exactly how the separatists
turned echo to the dark side but some
fans may already know how this
particular arc could play out for
unfinished Clone Wars episodes surfaced
online many years ago and they're still
available to watch today the episodes
make up wait for it the bad batch arc
and one installment is essentially the
exact same episode as the Clone Wars
season 7 premiere currently streaming on
Disney Plus this has led fans to believe
that perhaps some or all of the
previously leaked episodes were
completed for inclusion in the Clone
Wars season 7 bundle if this is the case
well the revelation that echo is alive
is only the start of some serious
trouble yet to come
Star Wars the Clone Wars season 7 will
return with episode 2 a distant echo on
Friday February 28th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]